today we're going to cancel
a teacher in virginia's loudoun county
public school district though really we
could cancel the whole school district
itself as it is a constant source of
exactly the sort of lunacy
we're going to discuss today as the
daily wire reports quote video footage
shows a virginia public school teacher
bullying a student for saying that he
takes a colorblind approach to observing
people a schoolteacher in virginia's
loudoun county public school district
one of the wealthiest districts in the
nation was caught on tape telling a
student
that it's important to see racial
differences when observing people
for a class assignment the teacher
posted a photo of two females one with
white skin and red hair another with
black skin
and black hair students were asked to
observe what they saw in the picture
one unnamed student responded by saying
he saw just two people chilling
the teacher called the student
intentionally coy for not categorizing
the women by their race
okay let's let's actually we have the
audio of that moment let's play that now
the story behind this picture um i'd
rather
hold on to that just coming with what
this seems to be a picture of
it's just two people chilling right
just two people that's nothing more to
this picture
no not really just two people chilling
i don't believe that you believe that um
i don't believe that you look at this as
just two people
um i don't think truly you're just two
people though is it not
yeah but i think you're being i think
you're being um
i think you're being intentionally coy
about what this is a picture of
what i mean being coy about it's two
people standing back to back in the
picture
yeah and that's all you see is two
people i i'm confused on what you would
like me to
to speak i don't think you are i don't
know why you do this
um i'm not trying to call you out but
you can you you
know you come out off of mute to talk
about what this is a picture of
and you act as if as if you know there's
nothing
noticeable about this apart from the two
people
well i'm confused are you trying to get
me to say that there are two different
races in this picture
well at the end of the day wouldn't that
just be feeding into the problem of
looking at race instead of just
acknowledging them as two normal people
if we're
going for let's say if we're looking for
equality within all this then why would
we need to point out things such as that
because those things those differences
are real things
a few points to make here first this is
what brainwashing sounds like in real
time the only difference between that
and most public school brainwashing is
that in in this case the student had the
wherewithal
to resist it now consider that most kids
not even kids but all people adults do
don't really possess the critical
thinking skills and backbone necessary
to defy
a perceived authority figure in that way
and they especially are incapable of
thinking and acting for themselves
when the issue at hand is something as
toxic and emotionally charged as race
and racism
because the implied threats and
sometimes over overt threat of course
is always if you don't agree with me and
adopt the correct views
you will be racist most people cave to
that threat very easily
because in our culture today being
called racist is the that is
the worst thing you can be labeled even
worse than being labeled like a
pedophile
to be to be labeled a racist is the
worst
and most people will cave to it
immediately now for kids
you can't blame them when they cave
because they're just kids for adults i
do blame them
yet that doesn't stop them from doing it
also notice the nature of this
brainwashing right
the students they're not just being
taught
to believe something like to believe a
certain proposition
to accept certain facts to remember
certain bits of data
rather they're being told how to think
the teacher is telling them how to see
other people think about that he wants
to change the way they fundamentally
view other human beings and he wants to
do this because he subjectively
personally
thinks that people should see other
humans this way
this is apparently how he sees other
people judging them by their race first
and foremost
and his mission now is to get the kids
uh their kid the kids brains to work the
same way
that his does he's like a it's like
imagine a schizophrenic
insisting that his students must all
learn how to hear voices in their head
like he does
it it's quite disturbing to think about
and even more disturbing when you
consider that millions of students
encounter this kind of mental
conditioning
every day and as we established most
are not going to be able to withstand it
second point
there's a great irony in this exchange i
believe that the girls in the picture
are named lucy and maria ailmeyer the
only reason i don't i know the name
is that they're a relatively well-known
case of twin sisters
who appear to be different races they
have a white father and a
jamaican mother this is a rare instance
where twins with interracial parents end
up individually resembling the race of
one parent or the other
but of course those girls are the same
race
they have the same genetic ethnic mix
just manifesting itself differently on
the outside
the point is that the student was more
right than he realized
he saw them as two people he didn't see
them initially as two different races
or at least he wasn't focused on that if
he had said oh i see a black woman and a
white
woman he would have been wrong he would
have been judging them based on their
appearance
and it would have led him to a false
conclusion so he avoided the false
conclusion by not focusing
on outward appearance and that's what
got him in trouble with the teacher
the teacher was mad at him because he
wasn't wrong
he said that two plus two equals four
and the teacher yelled at him for not
saying that it equals five
third point finally this relates back to
that sesame street clip we played last
week not the one with little nazex
there's been a lot of sesame street
related content on the show recently
um sesame street introduced some black
muppets whose job is to teach
four-year-olds about critical race
theory gone are the days of cookie
monster teaching that c is for cookie
you know they won't even let the poor
guy have his cookies anymore because of
the
obesity epidemic in any case in the clip
the puppet says that what's on the
outside is what makes us who we are
this is the same message that the
teacher in the video is trying to hammer
home
but this not only directly contradicts
what we were all taught growing up
and not only encourages exactly the kind
of racism that they're supposedly trying
to prevent
but it also of course flies in the face
of every single thing they say about
gender
if what's on the outside makes us who we
are
then wouldn't a penis make you a man
if if you're supposed to notice
somebody's race and find
significance in it then shouldn't we
notice their sex and find significance
in that
well apparently not we've learned that
at least in the confused mind of the
modern left
that that even though your biological
sex is more ingrained and more immutable
than your race
still somehow your race is this
changeless identifying characteristic
while your sex is fluid ever-changing
and ultimately inconsequential
is totally incoherent but that's part of
the point
you're not supposed to understand you
are supposed to simply accept
and obey and even if you don't believe
it at least pretend you believe it
this is the message especially in the
school system and it's why you should
think twice before sending your kids
into it
especially the loudoun county school
district in virginia which in any case
is now canceled listen hit that
subscribe button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated